my career when we were both PhD students
that would regularly attend the same
weekly qualm computing group meetings at
MIT so today Elizabeth Crossan is a
professor at the University of New
Mexico and we'll be hearing from her
about designing Hamiltonians
for quantum adiabatic optimization to be
ready to go go ahead with it
ok thanks Ryan for the introduction huh
ok so the title of my talk is designing
hamiltonians for adiabatic optimization
or if you like designing them
so I'm going to introduce a mathematical
operation that we call D signing I'll
mention that this work was done as part
of the quantum enhanced optimization
program and my collaborators to meme at
UNM e tie at USC and Peter Peter Young
as well um ok uh let me set up my screen
a little bit here okay so adiabatic
optimization
it's a heuristic quite an algorithm that
aims to minimize some real valued
function on n bit strings by remaining
close to the instantaneous ground state
of some parameterised Hamiltonian so H
of s where s is a parameter going from 0
to 1 and for this general description of
the algorithm we only require that the
ground state of H of 0 is easy to
initialize and H of 1 is a Hamiltonian
that encodes the function f in the
computational basis ok so as most of you
know that if we look at the minimum
spectral gap that occurs along this
adiabatic parameter between the ground
state and first excited state this gives
us a sufficient condition to upper bound
the runtime needed to find the ground
state of F by this method so I'll freeze
it here as the runtime is polynomial in
the
of qubits and the inverse of this
minimum spectral gap okay so while this
end point at s equals 1 is a fixed
classical Hamiltonian we might consider
various Hamiltonian paths as a function
of s that reached this end point and
when we do this the goal should be to
make the spectral gap as large as
possible subject maybe to hardware
constraints and so the original and most
well studied proposal of this kind is
transverse field adiabatic optimization
where we use where this Hamiltonian path
is a simple linear interpolation between
a uniform transverse field on the n
qubits and the final Hamiltonian the one
that encodes this function f so we just
interpolate between those two that was
the original proposal going back to the
mid-90s and is by far the most well
studied version but this notion of more
general paths will be important for this
talk ok so but this transverse field
adiabatic optimization this Hamiltonian
is a transverse Ising model that is a
type of stochastic Hamiltonian the
stochastic local Hamiltonian problem is
less complex than the general local
Hamiltonian problem so stochastic LH is
in a.m. and also on the physics side we
have classical simulations for ground
states of transverse Ising models that
are effective in practice and there are
some rigorous results about that too but
anyway given these limitations it's
we're motivated to study adiabatic
optimization the same overall idea but
with some kind of non stochastic
Hamiltonian describing the intermediate
path so that will be in the ground state
of a non stochastic Hamiltonian ok so
just to give you the definition so local
Hamiltonian is called stochastic if all
of its matrix elements in some local
basis like say the computational basis
are real and non positive ok the
elements of each local term and the key
point about this property is that
such Hamiltonian matrices can be scaled
and shifted into matrices with
non-negative entries and when you do
this the ground state becomes the
eigenvector with the largest eigen value
so matrices with non-negative entries
have a bunch of special properties and
that's what kind of limits the
complexity of these Hamiltonians and
enables these classical much carlo type
simulations okay so as it became
increasingly unlikely say from the
period 2005 to 2015 to find a quantum
speed-up with stochastic adiabatic
optimization so what do I mean is that
during that decade we saw several
theoretical results about limited ground
state complexity for these models and
then we also saw a lot of practical
efficient simulations so you know by
2015 the case was pretty clear at this
point and so our attention shifted to
the potential use of non stochastic or
just general quantum hamiltonians
in adiabatic operation now the main
arguments for making this shift were
indirect so the first is that you know
we know that 80 about a computation with
a non stochastic Hamiltonian can be
universal but note that the final
Hamiltonian in this universal adiabatic
construction is a fine man khatai of
history State Hamiltonian so it's not
the case that we're following some path
and ending on a classical optimization
Hamiltonian ok I used the term adiabatic
optimization to refer specifically to
ending on a classical Hamiltonian like
that okay the second piece of indirect
evidence to move towards non stochastic
Hamiltonians comes from again the fact
that we've had practically efficient
Monte Carlo simulations practically
efficient I just mean empirically write
these algorithms are run as heuristics
but you can see them converge at finite
system sizes so we have these simulation
this is this body kind of a simulation
evidence for transverse Ising ground
states but it is also known that these
simulations
breakdown in the non-stochastic case
because of the sign problem which
physicists have tried very hard to solve
to extend the range of simulations and
you know also for complexity reasons we
don't expect it to have a general
solution okay so those are the
motivations for considering non
stochastic adiabatic optimization circa
about five years ago so what is the
message for today well today we're going
to kind of see the conclusion of that
program and it's it's it's a negative
one from the perspective of obtaining a
quantum speed-up so today's message is
that non stochastic Hamiltonians may
make adiabatic optimization more
difficult to classically simulate but
they almost always decrease performance
by shrinking the spectral gap therefore
randomly chosen non stochastic eighty
about a Katz we do not believe are a
promising direction for quantum speed-up
so those are some pretty big claims and
I am going to give you evidences for
these and also you'll notice that I say
it almost always decreases or shrinks
the spectral gap so that almost always
is the reason that the story is
complicated and I have to present
various pieces of evidence ok so how do
we make the case overall so we introduce
new ways I'm going to just focus on one
of them in this talk to systematically
compare stochastic and non stochastic
hamiltonians in this type of context
adiabatic opt is a ssin they could also
be used to study different drivers in
queue AOA perhaps in the future so so
here's this mathematical operation so we
start from some original Hamiltonian
which may be non stochastic and here
I've written it in terms of its matrix
elements in say the computational basis
ok
and so the D signed hamiltonian h bar oh
oh I'm sorry there's a there's a there's
a typo there this should say is
stochastic I'm sorry the D signed
Hamiltonian H bar I've taken entry wise
matrix elements and I've made them real
and non positive you see this
absolute value simple so this should say
the D signed Hamiltonian is always
stochastic and ok so mathematically
I know this expression might seem
complicated so you can also think of an
equivalent mathematical version of this
problem we wish to compare the spectral
gaps at the top of the spectrum for a
hermitian matrix G and its entry wise
absolute value G bar okay so you could
just think of that mathematical problem
and all of this stuff about Hamiltonians
is motivational contents okay now what I
want to point out is that this designing
operation doesn't make sense in all
contexts for example if you you know D
sine of Fineman Kataya of history State
Hamiltonian then the resulting ground
state will be different from the one you
want okay but in the context of
adiabatic optimization where all you
want is some path with a large gap that
ends in a classical Hamiltonian then you
may as well than you may as well
consider H and H bar as roughly
equivalent just because you can think
about in hardware terms if you can
implement H well you should be able to
implement H bar or at least if H is K
local then H bar will be K local as well
okay so what we observe is that
designing almost always increases the
spectral gap for any reasonable ensemble
and any but any general theorem has to
be probabilistic because there are
exceptions to the statement that is
there are cases where the D signed
hamiltonian has a smaller gap but this
fraction of exceptional cases where the
D signed matrix has a smaller spectral
gap appears to go to zero with the
dimension of the matrix okay Elizabeth
can I ask you a question yes good thing
that you had started because at the
beginning you said over the adiabatic
the optimization you end up with a you
know some classical bit string but you
could say well I take a history stage
you know add a lot of identities so I
really have a lot of support on the fad
last configuration of my circuit and
let's say I've cleaned up the circuit so
that I've reversed everything and all
the qubits are back into zero except in
one register at the outcome of factoring
algorithm right sure though so that you
were construction would apply there well
I think that in that case it would not
apply because in the five- Hamiltonian
you would you would be taking sort of
this absolute value of the individual
gates and so you would be doing a
different computation than the one you
had intended to do right because this is
applying to all the matrix elements of
the hamiltonian for every value of s I
didn't S is implicit here but we're
gonna we're gonna do this absolute value
operation end stage or not I don't think
so if your original gates you know we're
doing some quantum Fourier transform and
had non-trivial phases in them then
taking the absolute value would change
those gates and and change the nature of
the computation resulting in a different
output state but yeah for the purpose of
this we're we're really just focused on
this s equals one is a purely classical
diagonal in the computational basis type
of Hamiltonian Luci yeah okay and so
okay so so what are what are the various
pieces of evidence that that you can
also see it our paper on the archive so
d signing is a nonlinear map and it's
going to in general change all the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors right but
as we just described it leaves classical
Hamiltonians unchanged because we didn't
do anything to the diagonal and so it
preserves the endpoints or at least the
final end point of the adiabatic path
so therefore the designed h of s should
be regarded as a new path through the
space of hamiltonians that connects
those endpoints right so you have your
original path and you're just comparing
it to a new path which is the d signed
version okay so our message about the
typical behavior of the spectral camp is
supported by various results some
rigorous some
so first we can give a rigorous proof in
the setting of random matrix ensembles
vikner matrices dense iid entries dense
matrices with iid entries so there we
can just prove prove this then an
example of a special case so suppose you
have some Hamiltonian that is diagonal
in the X basis but now you rotate to the
computational basis and the Hamiltonian
has both positive and negative phases
and it's matrix elements but now you
still now you design it in the
computational basis this always
increases the spectral gap we show that
one shot to enlightening we kind of used
the the Fourier expansion of this and
and just do a lengthy calculation but at
least this is one case where designing
deterministically increases the spectral
gap and of course it's interesting that
the original Hamiltonian was stochastic
in the X basis okay then we have some
results using the spectral theory of
signed graph laplacian x' to also help
explain the phenomenon and then finally
we see a clear trend in numerical
simulations for local Hamiltonians
that already emerges at low qubit number
so even though all of our arguments
support the same main conclusion random
local Hamiltonians are of course of
great interest but are difficult to
analyze you can't use these bigger type
methods so there we see a clear
numerical trend but can't prove the
apparent or expected result and i want
to draw attention to that open problem
ok so let me just run through a few sort
of initial observations a few things you
can prove so one thing you can show is
that designing always decreases the very
the ground energy so technically this
says it's non increasing but actually
this becomes strict under the condition
that you can't cure it cure the sign
problem with a diagonal unitary for the
experts the proof of this
decrease in the ground energy is that
you know if you take the original ground
state of the original Hamiltonian then
you can create this absolute value
ground state it's still normalized and
and you can show variational e that the
energy with respect to the D signed
Hamiltonian of this variational ground
state you know is less less than or
equal to the original so that's how you
prove that so now you take this fact so
suppose H is positive semi-definite
matrix then you know the sum of the
eigenvalues for both h and h bar have to
be equal and and yet we've decreased one
of you know we've decreased that least
eigenvalue and so you know this must
increase the spacing somewhere in the
spectrum I know it's a very general
argument so now notice that if if d
signing always increased the first
excited energy then we would that we
would be done we would show that d
signing always increases the spectral
gap but it turns out this just isn't
true in general ok so here's here's kind
of the argument for random matrices so
if you consider an ensemble of N by n
let's do random symmetric matrices with
iid entries of me and zero and variance
one well this is the gaussian orthogonal
ensemble and it has a very well-known
distribution of eigenvalues which are
distributed on this semicircle between
you know minus root n and + root n it
turns out this this semicircle property
just depends on the first few moments of
the iid of the distribution you're
drawing entries from and so the same
semicircle applies to coefficients and
minus 1 to 1 now since there are n
eigenvalues the typical spacing between
them then should be order root n 1 over
root n and then you know more precise
large deviation bounds for the spacing
are also well-known so we're gonna look
at the top of the spectrum here kind of
take the mathematical view okay so I'm
claiming this gap you know is is 1 over
polynomial
okay so now to compare that ensemble
with an ensemble that represents the D
signed or stochastic version of these
matrices define an ensemble now of
symmetric matrices with non-negative
iid entries so they're chosen now
uniformly from 0 to 1 now the key idea
is that each matrix in this new ensemble
is non-negative Ensemble can be obtained
from a matrix in the previous ensemble
by adding a matrix with a 1 in every
entry well and then dividing by 2 ok so
this so we're adding this Rank 1 matrix
the rank one matrix the matrix of all
ones it's got a single eigen value equal
to n and the rest of its eigenvalues are
0 and so in fact what this does is it
turns the largest eigenvalue into an
outlier and creates a huge spectral gap
at the top of the spectrum okay
so just to kind of drive that home
numerically here this is the case of
random matrices with iid entries up to
ten by ten matrices and when we say the
fraction of non stochastic winds those
are cases where the D signed Hamiltonian
actually had a smaller gap than the
original and so we see that that
fraction is basically going to zero
exponentially and it's even worse if the
original hamiltonians had complex matrix
entries it goes to zero even more
quickly so we just proved it but it's
also nice to do the numerix to see how
quickly this effect kicks in right so
okay all but ten to the minus six
fraction of the time the d signed
hamiltonian has a bigger spectral gap
okay so if I had a whole ton of time and
you guys are an expert audience who I
knew would be interested I would cover
these cheater inequalities in detail but
it's the kind of thing that is pretty
involved so let me see if I can do it
just a bit of justice for people who who
know the basic version of cheaters
inequality which says
that you know if you have a spectral gap
you can understand the spectrum sorry if
you have a graph you can understand the
spectrum of its normalized laplacian in
terms of the geometry of the graph and
any any graph laplacian in this sense
can be regarded as a quantum Hamiltonian
right it ends up being a symmetric
matrix where the vertices are basis
elements and the edge weights are matrix
elements so so what these what this part
of the paper is about is basically
saying you could take a graph with a set
of edges and vertices and you can
consider a signed version of that graph
where you've put plus positive and
negative phases on those edges and and
this signed version of the graph well
you can confuse some of these geometric
techniques to try to compare the
spectral gap of the unsigned graph the
original graph and the signed breadth
and this turns out to be exactly similar
to this designing that we're considering
in the Hamiltonian context so what we do
here is kind of neat we use some higher
order cheater inequalities so so so this
is called the Keith Order cheater
constant and it comes from you're not
just looking for the subsets that
maximize of the expansion you're
partitioning the graph into say four
subsets and you're considering the
minimum over all partitions of the
maximum expansion of any of those
subsets right and and then if you do
this the reason to do this with not just
two subsets as in the standard cheater
case but with K of them is that you can
actually get up to you the K eigen value
above the ground energy and you can get
these inequalities okay
so it turns out that about five to six
years ago graph theorists also worked
out
signed cheater inequalities and what
basically happens is that you have to
account not just for the edge expansion
and the standard piece but also for this
new frustration index which essentially
comes from the phases on edges
technically it's defined in terms of
trying to basically partition the
vertices into two subsets with no width
is the smallest number of internal
negative edges and the smallest number
of positive edges between them but
basically what this does this
frustration index is it pushes up all
the cheater constants and by the
higher-order cheater inequality it
pushes up all the eigenvalues of the
signed graph laplacian okay so in other
words here's the picture right in the
stochastic case we have you know we have
this big gap and in the non-stochastic
case the the first six the brown state
goes up the first excited state also
goes up but not as much and so on and so
the whole whole spectrum gets a bit
compressed again this is this is kind of
an attempt to explain what we're seeing
we prove kind of a we prove a theorem
that is based on the comparison of these
two graphs but it depends on some
geometric factors that are hard to
evaluate and I guess for reasons of time
maybe I can kind of come back to this
I want the essential takeaway point to
be that this this frustration index is
pushing up all the eigenvalues and
pushing up the ground energy by the most
I think that's what I can say okay and
lastly we did our numerical experiments
are based on a you know we just chose a
particular problem which is which is
maxcut for the final Hamiltonian and we
considered random path changes so here
can't see this term s times 1 minus s
becomes largest in the middle and we
chose the alpha I J's for married by
various methods we chose them randomly
we chose them uniformly you know there's
a lot of different things you can
consider and without so so basically all
of these graphs show the fraction of non
stochastic winds as the number
cubits say he goes up to 20 and
basically what you can see is that when
you take this random approach I mean
we're getting two percent right at best
so two percent of the time it's better
to use a random stochastic Hamiltonian
as opposed to it's designed counterpart
so if you just look at the y axes you
get very few non stochastic wins the
designed Hamiltonians are almost always
better and yeah that's kind of what I
want the main message to be so I think
it's worth reflecting on the history
just briefly these non stochastic
hamiltonians were one of the last great
hopes for this original proposal of
adiabatic operation and you know perhaps
in the NIST era we've seen a lot of
equivocation between hardness of
classical simulation and useful
algorithmic enhancement so this is a
case where those two did not go together
right the those non stochastic
hamiltonians are harder to simulate but
they're actually worse in terms of
algorithmic performance okay and so
basically given the body of negative
results you know we this heuristic
quantum optimization community that has
worked on these kind of things you know
they're we're kind of being forced to
leave the ground state and you know an
intriguing new direction is this
diabetic quantum annealing which is
found to be related to the quantum
approximate opposition algorithm so
here's a here's a quote from a paper our
results indicate that qlae is closely
related to a cleverly optimized diabetic
quantum annealing path that can overcome
limitations set by the adiabatic theorem
so when I say diabetic I mean you're
going faster than the rate that would be
allowed by the adiabatic theorem and so
you're leaving the ground state ground
state and exploring higher parts of the
spectrum that's that's one direction
this community could go in and then
another view is that perhaps as
theorists we should be trying to treat
these heuristic optimization algorithms
more generally right so you know perhaps
a general shortcoming is that they
aren't treating they're using enough
structure of the problem to really get a
quantum speed-up
so maybe there's some some way to
formulate a general no-go result for
these algorithms that that attempt to
just use gates or dynamics generated by
the classical problem Hamiltonian kind
of a wild idea but it would be nice to
stop playing whack-a-mole where the
goalposts keep shifting and we have to
address new proposals that are harder to
analyze and get something a little more
sweeping you know it took us at least
five years to resolve this non
stochastic question and we would like to
if we're wrong prove ourselves wrong
more quickly than that thank you thanks
Elizabeth for that talk does anyone in
the audience have any questions for
Elizabeth you can enter them into the
Q&A
all right I suppose not I so in this
case I suppose this concludes the
conference for today so thank you all
for participating and maybe let's have a
round of applause for our speakers